you know the last time I virtually saw
you you were joined by your fellow
Sister Wives and here we are in 2022
things are a little bit different so
first things first just how are you
doing I'm doing fabulous thank you so
much it's good to see you too Again by
the way yay um doing great actually
doing really really well love and love
and living in Utah close to my kids it's
been fabulous yes I mean I I imagine
that we have a lot to catch up on right
now because so much in your life has
changed
um a huge storyline that we're seeing
currently play out on Sister Wives is
you stepping away from Cody and kind of
stepping away from plural marriage how
do we unravel something that's been
together for this long there's something
unraveling
it's just gonna look different since you
made that big decision how has your life
changed you know everything is a lot
more simple than it used to be which I
didn't even think about but I'm single
now right so I kind of just decide what
I want to do and then do it and it's
been just very very simple like no
committed decisions anymore and
everything's just a lot easier as far as
just planning in day-to-day life and I
really just feel like this is the path
I'm supposed to be on now yeah so I
firmly believe plague me was what I was
supposed to do and everything and that's
all great and now though yeah I get to
be done so it's more like a personal
strength that I feel like I have more
than I've ever felt before because I was
able to make steps for my future and for
my present and so I just feel more
confident as well I feel your energy
through this camera through this screen
I feel like it's a lighter easier
breezier Christine I mean do you feel
like a weight has been lifted off your
shoulders you know what enormous us
weight has been lifted I'm watching the
episodes is hard that definitely puts me
back to where more somber
um definitely but living my life every
day day to day I would say it's so much
better I think just because I'm so more
grounded and I just like my I just like
me and I like my life so much better now
and I didn't even know I didn't like it
before really you know I just thought
well I'm doing it and this is what I'm
gonna do but now no so much better so
much more confident I think it just
comes through yeah it does and now I
guess it begs the question do you feel
like you should have done this sooner do
you think you would have gotten to this
happy lighter place in life if you had
maybe made this decision sooner no
honestly I think that I've been if I
made the decision sooner I might have
left out of anger you know if I decided
to not come and stay in Vegas or even
sooner in Flags I think it would have
been out of anger and that would have
been a mistake and then same thing with
leaving later
um coding I probably would have started
fighting I imagine you know it's just
something I was not it was just perfect
the timing for me to leave was just it
opened up and everything became just
things fell into place so well so no and
I'm never gonna once I decided to just I
kind of looked at where my life was and
before I decided to leave and I'm like
do I really want to do this for another
10 years and I decided no I really
didn't and so I started moving forward
and I just don't I don't I didn't look
back I never looked back I just started
moving forward there is no looking back
like you just said you are looking
forward and this new chapter of
Christine what does it look like
um I I just been having just more fun
and getting truly around her siblings
more around my mom more and my dad I've
just been able to hang out with family
my brothers and sisters uh yeah my
parents my kids more often than ever
before and I think it's complete it's
making like truly more well-grounded as
well and more confident she won students
of the month last month at her school so
I just think that she's doing so great
truly has been on my heart since this
most recent episode so mckelty called me
right as I was walking down the stairs
into the kitchen she's so excited I'm
moving to Utah
and I said yeah I'm excited to move too
and then I heard a gasp
when I looked behind me and there was
truly
a really heartbreaking moment how is she
doing
so good and true as she had a bit better
than I thought she would as far as the
divorce went I think it's that's because
I wasn't like stringing her along like
it was more of a oh they're getting
divorced I guess it's over and she
didn't have to think are they really
going to get divorced she just asked are
you and Dad Gonna Get Along I'm like
yeah we're gonna get along just fine and
then she was more upset about moving
than anything okay and how has she
adjusted to that perfectly lovely okay
yeah after we were here like
a couple weeks she just kept talking
about I love our life now I just love
our life so she suggested really well I
want to ask you because you know we're
watching so much of your life play out
on television but here you're in front
of me and you seem to me better than
ever so I'm curious where does your
relationship with Cody stand today so
Cody and I just talked the other day on
the phone just about truly I told him
that she had one student of the month
and he was just thrilled for her and
then I was heading to Flagstaff and he
asked if she would be coming with and
I'm like not this time it should be
coming coming next time and you can hang
out with her then and that's our
conversation like we keep it really
brief but we're going to be cordial you
know so we were just I saw them Robin
and Cody at a family event recently
mckelvey's um baby shower and they came
and everything and
I was a little bit not sure but we were
fine we're fine you know it's hard it's
difficult but I we're hopefully going to
be fine you know I think I was a lot
more optimistic that we would be dyked
besties so I'm not quite sure about that
but we'll see okay so you were
optimistic that it would be very much
each other you know a presence in each
other's lives and you feel like there's
a little bit of distance between you and
the rest of the of the family right now
I'm requiring a bit of a distance to be
honest with you I feel like I'm just
starting to get to know me and I really
like me and I want to keep it that way
and I also want to keep things as easy
emotionally since truly's around me all
the time too so for right now
everything's just gonna stay as is with
all of the relationships you know we're
not going to get any closer at all I'm
super close with Janelle that's that's
of course very different uh just Janelle
and I are to probably just continue I
don't know if you can be Sister Wives
you know if you're not really but I just
consider tell my sister if she just
always will be and so we vacation
together and we've hung out together so
we're fine together okay so is it fair
to say that maybe Janelle has been the
most supportive sister wife in all of
this oh for sure because she's been with
me for years during my frustration with
being married and just whatever you know
you talk to I know I used to vent to
Robin too but I certainly vented more to
Janelle she's and she would be like you
need to [ __ ] up this is ridiculous you
are just fine yeah all the time I love
that okay so if Janelle gets like the
most supportive sister award is there a
sister that you feel like there's the
most distance between the two of you
like I won't be close with Mary anymore
not really we're just a very different
and so we we won't I won't really be
having that much to do with Mary so much
you know I wish her the best I wish her
all the happiness in the world of course
and whatever she needs I hope she gets
that I just don't see that there's a
friendship for us how often are you
communicating with with Cody with Robin
with the rest of your Sister Wives I
only talked to Cody when it really
evolves truly I'd say just very very
rarely I mean even since I left we went
out to eat together one time just to get
on the same page for the holidays last
year so it's it's been a while since
since I actually just had a real
conversation I think that everybody's
still
it's hard when you live it and then when
you get to see it and relive it again
it's very difficult emotionally so right
now while the episodes are airing it's
all very raw again so right now it's a
little more difficult because we're
seeing the episodes too what does your
future with Sister Wives look like as
you have you know now disassociated
yourself from the family will you
continue on the show or is a Christine
spin-off on the table oh that'd be fun I
don't know so as far as the family goes
I'm still with half the family Janelle
and her kids I am still with them so as
far as Sister Wives go I'll still be
doing things with Janelle quite
regularly as far as the spin-off dude
I'm totally open no idea what it looks
like but absolutely that'd be just fun
as heck okay so fingers crossed for a
spin-off but you're not going anywhere
in terms of Sister Wives the television
show absolutely not like I made like a
promise to like Cody and everybody else
and I will stay with Sister Wives as
long as we have the show just to be fair
it's what our families been doing for so
long and so no I absolutely I feel like
it would be disloyal if I you know
decided to not be part of the show you
said earlier that you're a single girl
are are you dating are you interested in
exploring a romantic relationship at
this point okay not romantic yeah that's
jumping way too fast but dating for sure
I'm dating just for fun you know that
just keeping everything super light
because that's just who I am right now
I'm just gonna keep everything like
nothing serious dating sure as long as
it's just like I don't know just very
very casually I'm sure absolutely
romantic relationship eventually married
again eventually yes after everything
you've been through what is it you're
looking for in a new partner
um kindness
um real just kindness and romantic
relationship for sure someone's who's
attracted to me would be a really great
thing I'm just saying so yeah all of
that
[Music]